i really want to see if there's a way
to harmonize
the idea of the single reality whose
nature is consciousness
with the idea of the
so-called material but
evolution specifically the fact that
there has been an
evolutionary process to get us
um to this point so what
how do you um bring the topics
together of the fact there has been this
evolutionary process
for the um knowing
to be enabled well can we reconcile
idealism with matter
well there is this thing out there
and even in us that we call matter right
there can be a dispute about
what is it exactly how do we
conceptualize it
what true statements can we can we make
about it and what
false statements but there is this thing
we see
smell touch that that's undeniable so if
idealism cannot
be reconcilable with that it's just
plain wrong right because
there is this thing out there i think
it's completely reconcilable because you
see
we only know matter insofar as we
experience it
if there is something out there that
nobody ever has experienced it might as
well not exist
it becomes just a conceptual inferential
reality it doesn't have any
any true existence what idealism would
say is that
what we call matter is what conscious
inner life looks like from a certain
perspective
to be more specific i would say from
across a dissociative boundary but then
you start getting into the details
so matter is just what conscious in your
life looks like
from a perspective if i look in the
mirror i see
my conscious inner life presenting
itself to me in the form of an image
in the mirror if i look at somebody
else's brain under a brain scanner
the images i will see on the monitor of
the brain scanner are what the inner
life of that person the conscious in
their life of that person
will be looking like from my perspective
so i would even define matter as what
experiential states look like
from a perspective and is there
something beyond matter of course
there are other experiential states that
are not directly translatable into
matter like
our endogenous feelings our emotions uh
even some of our abstract thoughts
what we call matter is what presents
itself on the screen of perception
in a sense it is perception but there
are more experiential states than just
perceptual states if i lock you up in an
ideal sensory deprivation chamber
and you can't hear see touch smell
anything you will still
have experiential states you still you
still have experiential states like
desire
fear uh thoughts
emotions of every kind so matter is one
part of the puzzle and it's certainly
reconcilable with the
idealism oh sorry i gave you an extended
the answer i forgot the second part of
your question
with evolution um we have very very good
reasons
to infer um that the organization of
living organisms has evolved not only
that even the universe
has evolved it started as a fairly
uniform
framework so to say and then because of
quantum fluctuations and gravity being
applicable to those quantum fluctuations
it started differentiating itself and
formed you know eventually you know
matter and stars and planets and moons
and
life we have plenty of evidence to
indicate that and i also don't think
any of that is is incompatible with
idealism on the contrary it's even it
even substantiates idealism because
even if everything is consciousness it's
not only your or my
consciousness alone it's a transpersonal
consciousness so to say especially
unbound
so we have to account for how individual
private consciousness has arisen within
this trans personal background and
that's evolution right there
okay so
out of the
which you've called a like a cosmic
consciousness or other people call an
infinite consciousness
there is a and there is an
a private consciousness as is that our
individual
um consciousness that that forms and i
really like how
uh rupert spyra has talked about this
idea of the perforation
and like the more that you preferate uh
the
the this circle of the individual or the
private consciousness the more that you
truly feel
like you are and sri aurobindo has
talked about the simultaneity
being a key of life can you
simultaneously be an individual
be the universal and the transcendent at
the same time
i think that's a really beautiful way to
also
put it i like i like how yeah i'm
i totally vibe on the idea that these
are absolutely compatible things
i think you know in sri aurobindo also
said that one of the main keys to life
is to just never cut life into two
and if you if you do that if you always
keep it at one
every time you try and break these
concepts into this materialism versus
idealism and
and like you try and like consciousness
only versus materials it's just it's
just this idea of like breaking it up
and trying to like
um i liked your point about sensory
deprivation i think that's an
interesting one so even if i'm
because especially for those that have
been in sensory deprivation tanks i
think
that's extremely salient because if you
have been in them
you know that it it's just
it it really in a sense it also kind of
feels like the womb
and i think that's really uh beautiful
but
and occasionally sure you can maybe hear
like a little bit of the
warm water like slosh against the side
but really you're you're there
completely sensory deprived and
if you don't have a good job of taming
the
the elephant i mean the elephant is
you know can be on cocaine and just your
mind the elephant monkey mind just you
know
and so if you yeah and so that's the
idea that you still
get some sort of bubbles of experience
uh even during a complete sensory
deprivation i would say it's the prime
directive of mind
its prime directive is not to be quiet
it is to generate experiences and digest
experiences and then deceive itself
because if there is no deception at some
level of reality
then everything just poof goes out of
existence
so uh reality uh is fundamentally
dependent on
a certain level of self-deception i'm
not saying that it's personal only there
could be something transpersonal behind
it
but it's the nature of mind your things
up and deceive itself in the process
so when you are in a sensory deprivation
chamber you may feel very quiet in the
beginning
but wait a little longer and you start
seeing that it's almost impossible
to stop that that dynamism that dynamic
activity of mind
to produce images produce thoughts
produce narratives and then deceive
itself
get get gets all tied up in its own
narrative
it's it's the nature of the beast yeah